the scoot you know scooters and a lot of
the kind of um
automotive companies and you know all
the designs that they're creating
they're for people who are they they
never actually create models that are
for the majority of the country right
and that's
this is very problematic and even when
you look at it never thought of that yes
right and so when you look at any of the
scooter comp i mean any of them no one
is designing things that actually
result that actually fit the the
customer globally like this is this is a
global issue right
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with leumitech
sponsored by hippo insurance opposed
labs touring hillel at stanford leap and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i am joined today by jessica
richmond trade and investment director
the australian trade
jessica serves as a san francisco-based
trade and investment director for the
australian trade and investment
commission in this role jessica helps us
based tech companies launch and expand
in australia
she also assists australian tech
companies with their us expansion
additionally jessica acts as founder and
ceo of the visible collective where she
advises companies on product development
marketing and new business development
to better serve customers labeled
overweight or obese by the centers for
disease control and prevention
ms richmond previously held roles in
marketing growth and strategy at
walmart.com one of her greatest
achievements was a 10-month solo
around-the-world trip jessica richmond
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
good how are you thank you for having me
thank you so much for being here i'm
really honored to have you here you're
the director of investment in quantum
technologies lead for the australian
trade and investment commission
well i'll have to understand a little
bit about what that means but what i'm
also curious to talk to you about is
your work as the founder and ceo of the
visible collective
working to advise companies to better
serve people of size and obviously you
know this is a something that
we know and we we're aware of and it's a
growing global um epidemic right in in
the last few decades and so i'm really
excited to understand from a more of a
pro from a company's perspective and
from a product development perspective
some of your thoughts but jessica tell
me a little bit about your your journey
and how do you find yourself converging
to these two verticals that you're
working on
absolutely so my journey is very
circuitous um i grew up in
i grew up in los angeles and kind of did
did a variety of different things there
as a as a as a kid i
worked in an entertainment pr agency i
work dressing models and styling them
for the runway
um i worked at planet hollywood for two
summers i completely forgot that which
is a very formative experience so
i i kind of just had a lot of we have to
do
this episode is now going to be on
planet hollywood what did you do to find
in hollywood so i was a i was a um
a merchandise salesperson
at planet hollywood and like uh and like
an assistant hostess at planet hollywood
so it was the one in beverly hills it
was a very uh it was a very interesting
environment um
at the time
yeah all right so
what happens after
so um and and then kind of i i took that
journey to go to go to uc berkeley cal
go bears i know i know you're a stanford
stanford person but i have to plug the
plug in the go bears so um and and there
i studied business at the at the
business school undergrad
and um
just kind of used some of the knowledge
that i had learned and developed in
various kind of internships and roles
in la throughout high school i was
always kind of working throughout high
school and kind of doing interesting
different projects um and after after
how i went to go work for walmart for
almost nine years in a in a variety of
different roles um primarily focused on
kind of marketing and strategy
uh at walmart
where i was kind of marketing
marketing managing
various categories at walmart so it
could have been apparel could have been
sporting goods
um consumables kind of health and
wellness various different divisions
that i was working in and also kind of
running some of the larger holiday
campaigns and working with different
brands to help them kind of plug into
some of those campaigns and working with
arkansas
because i was with walmart.com working
with arkansas to create more omnichannel
campaigns so learned a lot about
different products and different
customer needs there
and and how kind of to focus really on
the customer and what their what their
needs and their wants are so that's kind
of that
the beginning of it then i left to go
travel around the around the world for
about a year um by myself which was
which was very phenomenal um and and of
course i ran into israelis everywhere um
as one does um in particular in bolivia
uh that was a thousand that was a
that was actually someone tried to speak
hebrew to me on the on on a bus going
from one city to another and i and i had
they asked me like 25 years ago i would
have spoken fluent hebrew but but it's
been a long time so um
but but that was a very memorable
experience it was for someone from
shalomi's tours i i love it so um the
you know after that experience i think
and i spent eight of eight months of
that in in asia and it was very clear to
me that asia
asia is dynamic and that whole region is
really
there's so much future growth occurring
there
so i had a really a really strong
passion for that region and i actually
never made it to australia it's
important to note i never made it to
australia but when i came back i worked
in some startups and then i worked um i
thought that i wanted to run a jewelry
business so i actually went to go work
at a jewelry store helping
clients
with picking out specific gifts with
designing engagement rings understanding
more about various gemstones
and diamonds i like diamonds but i'm a
fan of sapphires aussie sapphires in
particular um and
the it just occurred to me after working
there for a couple of months that that
was not that was not what i was going to
do that was not my calling i like to buy
jewelry but i think you know i and and
and i like to talk about jewelry but i
didn't think i wanted to sell jewelry so
i landed at the the australian trade
investment commission which is really
the commercial arm of the australian
government
and our focus is my focus particularly
based in in the bay area is helping
tech companies launch offices and um
you know do r d in australia and also
helping and this is kind of a lesser
part of my job but helping australian
companies launch in the united states
so that's really what my focus is and
and the
the objectives really drive australia's
economic development
right so as they develop in the united
states they obviously bring back and and
and help and help australia prosper now
very very quickly before we move to the
visible collective what what does it
entail to to help australian companies
break through to the us market is it
mainly then in cultural understandings
and in networking and and and helping
them get a foothold on the ground what
does that actually tangibly mean yeah
it's it's it really is individualized to
the different company and where they
actually are at in their journey
um
a lot of it is
understanding yes cultural differences
which of which there are many there
there you know we speak the same
language but um
as a friend once said we're divided by a
common language um
we speak it but it's very very different
very different culture so i think that's
a really big part of it um it's also
just understanding silicon valley
culture especially if people are coming
here which is also another you know
beast um rather than you we all know
that silicon valley is very different
than than the rest of the country and
then
it's generally it
in my particular case because i have
colleagues who work on like more of the
specifics around how do you register the
company and how do you kind of do stuff
like that but my focus is really who are
the
who are the key people in your industry
that you can talk to who are going to
help you really understand the industry
in the united states and that's kind of
a lot of the work i do is you know
connecting people to
other key people who will provide them
with the
the right information um and and it's
also kind of working with investors as
well and kind of getting people
networked into and you know networked
into investors um so it really depends
on what the individual individual needs
are of the client at the time but you
know i've worked with with many of the
many of the the well-known aussie
companies that have that have grown
quickly here and and you know are
growing quickly here um that you've
probably heard of so it's i i i i'm not
really supposed to speak about
particular clients but
the ones you're hearing of in the in the
news lately probably are ones that i'm
talking to
and working with or have worked with yep
amazing so so two and a half years ago
you started the visible collective tell
me a little bit about even you know
before the for what the visible
collective actually does tell me a
little bit about the pain point that
you're working on solving you know on
on the other vertical that you're in
yeah so
it's really i'll start off with it's
really challenging um and what is and
and and i'll start off with how i got
there so
i have always been
existing in in a larger body like a fat
body whatever whatever people call it i
in my particular case i don't i don't
think that the word overweight or obese
is a customer facing term nor do the
majority of customers by the way they're
very medical terms
but like from a descriptive perspective
i live in a in a fat body and i don't i
don't see it as a bad word so i've
always kind of grown up with it with an
eating disorder i've always had kind of
issues with binge eating my whole entire
life
i've tried
everything you can imagine in the entire
world to try to change that um but i've
kind of come to this this this place of
kind of trying to learn and live and
accept my body and and figure out what
it means to exist in the world in my
body now
how this translates so so so taking that
into into mind right um then take into
consideration all the work at walmart
with understanding the customer and with
really
working in every different category that
the customer would shop in every every
category
and
it occurred to me that there's really a
there's a lack of understanding of the
fact that
pretty much every
product and service will likely need to
change as a result of people looking
different across across the world
yes and so when we talk about
you know and and i and a lot of my a lot
of my my job is also right education so
you know when you speak about
when you speak about kind of epidemics
and pandemics related to you know
related to this particular
customer you know i i encourage you and
it's and it's everyone i mean this is
this is when i say education it's a lot
of education it's you know would you
refer like people are aging globally
right but would you refer to it as like
a pandemic or an epidemic like not right
like there's there's there's a sense of
judgment that you know right we also
think about what words do we use and how
does that create a sense of judgment for
a group of people because i guarantee
you as one of those people
you know and i've been many different
sizes my whole life it's not like you
know i've been but they've all been in
the double digits of clothing sizes
right which which would i you know fall
into what is considered a higher bmi so
you know i would urge you to think about
what do kind of the words i say mean
because
the that group this group of people like
there's already so much judgment and we
already spend pretty much 90 of the day
judging ourselves right that it's like
adding an additional layer adds more
complexity but
you know when it's not and is not
helpful and i think so that's one of the
first things that i have to kind of
educate people about is you know a lot
of organizations and especially in
silicon valley a lot of the companies
that are getting funded they're it's
they're about weight loss right
and they're about and and
and when you look at statistics it is
very challenging to lose it is very
challenging to lose weight and to keep
it off very very challenging now if
that's the case and if we as
a society
kind of
come to acknowledge that that's the case
the question then becomes how do we meet
the customer where they're at
um whether it is with healthy healthy
eating startup like what like
whatever field you're in if it's an auto
like i think a lot about um the scoot
you know scooters and a lot of the kind
of um
automotive companies and you know all
the designs that they're creating
they're for people who are they they'd
never actually create models that are
for the majority of the country right
and that's
this is very problematic and even when
you look at it never thought of that yes
right and so when you look at any of the
scooter comp i mean any of them no one
is designing things that actually
result that actually fit the the
customer globally like this is this is a
global issue right like we talk about
china we talk about the united states
you know this is this is happening
pretty much in all in in all major
developed countries that people are
getting larger so you know what i
what i try to elevate with companies you
know whether it's a transportation
company or it's a healthcare company or
it's an insurance company is
how do you create paradigms that
actually fit the customer as they are
and as frankly they're going to be
because
not only
you know are people going to be larger
but generally when people are larger
their children their children are larger
and so the question also then becomes
and i'm not i'm look i'm not saying
it's all up to the individual customer
right like everyone has their own lives
and everyone has their own body and
that's another thing is companies
shouldn't you know companies and
individuals shouldn't judge people but
you know if someone wants to kind of go
and pursue whatever plan that they want
to pursue or they want to eat
differently or they want to eat healthy
you know whatever it is
we should just meet that customer where
they're at and not create a paradigm
from which you know where
where we're coming from and i think
that's that's the big thing that that
people don't under understand
and so that's kind of how i work with
companies and help help educate them so
they do understand that
a bit jessica even from a purely
economic perspective like the example
that you mentioned with the with the
with the automotive right and the trans
and the scooters yep why is it that the
scooter companies don't understand
internally that they need to cater to
the majority of the population
which may not be comfortable or may not
fit this this tiny tiny scooters that
they're designing i and now i'm
generally i'm wondering this
um
i wonder it too
uh and frankly and and and it's not only
the scooter companies but it's actually
it's actually the automotive industry at
large
um it is problematic so the majority of
people especially women so historically
cars were tested with with male bodies
and they were tested with not
necessarily with you know obese male
bodies right i'll use it for the
purposes of descriptor
so what what happens is the majority of
people especially women
who are larger which is a very large
percentage the country are driving on
say in cars unsafely because they
haven't been tested for that and so
you know you ask
and this is a well-documented thing if
you google it you can find crash test
dummies you know not reflective of the
population this is a very common and
there are there are companies like human
etix and different companies that are
trying to address this with different
crash test dummies but
you know the it comes but down to a
policy level right so and this is where
a lot of the you know when you look at a
lot of the transport companies unless
the policy changes right unless there's
policy changes on a government level
there's not going to necessarily be
changes on an individual company level
um
there are companies that design
transportation solutions
for larger bodies like there are there
are bicycle companies that there are
different companies like that but
it does shock me that
you know that the the
the majority of the companies don't
really look at this as a as an issue i
mean maybe it's because there's more
short-term thinking around let's create
a product let's grow the market let's
sell it right and it's not around
creating long-term sustainable companies
right so i think there's part of that if
you're just looking to
create and this is where i go back to
like a lot of the companies that are in
the space of like
in the space of i'll just i'll call it
the diet space right
for the sake of i'm not going to call it
the sustainable healthcare space i'm
going to call it the diet space
and a lot of them they're looking for
they're looking for not to create
sustainable companies but but they're
looking for how do we get the fastest
return in the fastest time possible
right and
so
yes you could look at this and say yes
there's a lot of fat people in the
united states how can we help them get
thinner you know how can we generate
significant data that's going to you
know make a health care company buy us
right and and that that's fairly
you know that that's that's a
straightforward well-trodden path it's
much more difficult to create a path of
let's really understand the customer
let's continue on a journey with them
their whole lives you know and and and
that's
that's really
what i'm trying to get companies to
understand and and
it's hard especially because you know
one of the challenges is
people who are who are in larger bodies
it's not a protected class in the united
states and so
a lot of the work that companies do
especially in the diversity inclusion
space can inform their product
development right and so we see a lot
more people hiring you know people of
color and people of different genders
and and sexual identities and
orientations and that can help inform
product development
um and that and by the way and it's also
mandated by the by the government that
you can't discriminate right against
those people it's not mandated by the
federal government that you can't
discriminate against someone based on
size so
you are also then
missing out on talent that can help you
identify
well how are you
forgetting the fact that the majority of
the country actually doesn't look like
you right and i think that really
becomes an issue in places in coastal
places and particularly in places like
the bay area where
the truth is that they're they're that
it's it's it's it's harder to find
someone who is considered fat to hire
right like because it's just not the the
demographics are different than they
would be in the midwest or in the south
so i i think personally the majority of
the interesting companies and product
development will likely come out of
places where people experience the
problem set
right wow jessica i think that
you've opened up a new type of thinking
for me
and i think it's going to take some time
to sink in and and i really appreciate
you coming on and sharing because i it
makes perfect sense and and i think
there's obviously the way that the
societal way of looking at but i'm also
an economic way of looking at it purely
you know for the for the benefit for the
win-win situation
it makes a lot of sense so thank you for
taking the time to share with me and
jessica take me back to your childhood a
little bit what what really fascinated
you as a kid
you know
everything
i know that's a weird response um
but you know to to go back i i loved i
loved fashion as a kid i loved fashion
um growing up in la and kind of growing
up um especially in my formative years
in in beverly hills from like the 8th to
12th grade i was really interested in it
you know and this by the way also
informs the visible collect i was
interested in it but no one ever
designed anything that would fit my body
right and at that point i was like
you know really much much smaller and
even then companies weren't kind of
designing things right like like that
would fit me so i think
that just that
juxtaposition was was very interesting
and growing up with that um so i think
fashion always interested many people
always interested me i mean
all
all people right like
i when i was at planet hollywood you
know i became very good friends with all
the people that work there and i became
friends with like the random celebrities
that would come in planet hollywood um
uh like gary coleman or like you know
different different random celebrities
that had been around for a long time
that would still come um i always think
and i think i learned this from i think
i learned this from my mom um because
she would always talk to everyone and i
always believe that everyone has
something to teach us everyone
like every single person
um
and so i think people really when it
comes down to it i guess it's really
people that fascinate me um and i so i
try to engage in as many conversations
as possible um and my my office actually
my the australian consulate makes fun of
me because i always end up meeting
australians everywhere i go
and kind of bringing them you know
bringing them back and kind of looping
them into what the consulate's doing and
that's a part of how i've you know kind
of succeeded in my job is because i do
talk to everyone and i am very
attentive in terms of accents and in
terms of what people are talking about
amazing amazing and what inspires you
today in your in your day-to-day work
either with the australian government
whether it be with the visible
collective or or anything personally
yeah i think um
helping helping individuals and helping
so in my work with with australian trade
commission it's really it's helping
people and helping companies succeed i
think that's one thing i get significant
joy from that um and then
in terms of visible collective and this
is why it's harder it's
transforming the way the perce
transforming perception globally
um and that that is a that is a lifetime
job right that many lifetime job right
is how do you how do you transform
perceptions and i do believe that
business is a tool if you can make
people see the economic value
right in doing something that arguably
can also help transform the way
that can help transform people's
perceptions so there's a significant
uh connection between that
that goal and being able to to help
people understand economically what the
impact is
i love it and jessica what are three
words you would use to describe yourself
so i thought about this and i thought
about it again um
the i think inquisitive is definitely
one um to the point where it's it's i
ask a lot of questions which i think
annoys my sometimes definitely annoying
my classmates in school um sometimes
annoys my colleagues now and definitely
annoys my boyfriend um
and uh a networker i i try to
meet as many people as possible and then
also kind of related to inquisitive is
is also kind of engaged right like it's
not only
being wanting to learn more but it's
then actually like once you start
talking to me actually just like
continuing to care about what you're
saying and being you know genuinely
engaged in what and what you're talking
about
amazing
jessica thank you so much this was so
great and thank you for sharing your
your passions and your work which is
fascinating and opening up some
interesting questions that i need to ask
now so thank you very much and stay safe
and stay healthy thank you thanks you
too